bonsoir Monsieur Pinault
bonsoir est-ce que vous trouvez comme
bien bien des gens que le moment est
quand même drôlement choisi là pour
lancer cet appel drop d'offre là on est
juste après la campagne on a entendu
François Legault critiquer sans cesse ce
qu'il appelait la taxe orange Québec
solidaire donc qui proposait de taxer
les véhicules les plus polluants quel
est l'objectif du gouvernement dans ce
cas-ci c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose
mais c'est certain que le gouvernement
ne voulait pas parler de ce dossier là
même si c'est un dossier incontournable
il y a un rapport de consultation qui
avait été déjà déposé sur le financement
de la mobilité durable et ce rapport-là
il avait été véritablement retardé il a
été déposé en catimini sur le site du
ministère du Transport et en fait il
recommandait d'aller vers les solutions
que vous venez de présenter et d'étudier
ces solutions là mais le ministère des
Transports on n'a jamais véritablement
parlé ouvertement le ministère des
Finances non plus parce que c'est un
problème aussi qui touche le ministère
des Finances puisqu'il faut combler le
déficit à venir le manque à gagner des
réductions de perception de taxes sur
les carburants donc c'est un sujet
incontournable ça aurait dû être un
sujet de campagne électorale parce qu'on
parle beaucoup d'électrification des
transports mais c'est inévitable la taxe
sur les carburants va diminuer en termes
de revenus et donc ça aurait dû être un
sujet débattu par les Québécois parce
que c'est un sujet important et
évidemment le gouvernement ne veut pas
en parler parce qu'il y a de d'autres
manières que d'introduire un nouvel
outil et c'est pas étonnant que il le
fasse en catimini comme ça maintenant à
travers une étude bon là à partir de
maintenant quand même cet appel d'offre
est lancée on veut réfléchir au cours
des prochains mois sur plusieurs mesures
pour rappeler que la taxe sur le carbone
monsieur Pino c'est à peu près 2
milliards de dollars par année au fond
des réseaux de transport terrestres la
vente des véhicules neuf à essence sera
carrément interdite en 2035 donc le
manque à gagner sera important en fait
qui sera privé de c'est ça à quoi
servent ces sommes exactement
alors juste une correction vous avez dit
que c'était la taxe sur le carbone et 2
milliards de dollars mais c'est la taxe
sur les carburants la taxe le prix du
carbone va financer autre chose mais
donc c'est 2 milliards là sont versés au
fond consolidé sur le transport routier
qu'on appelle le fort et qui vient
financer le réseau routier mais aussi le
transport en commun mais évidemment la
part du lion est véritablement dédiée
aux routes du Québec et ça vient donc
directement financer les routes du
Québec et d'autres activités de
transport notamment le transport en
commun si il est bien on ne comble pas
ce manque à gagner de 2 milliards là qui
va s'amenuiser au fil des années au fur
et à mesure que les ventes de carburant
diminuent et bien c'est les routes du
Québec qui vont empathir et directement
les automobilistes qui utilisent ces
routes là donc l'appel d'offres évoque
plusieurs outils de financement à
analyser on parle d'augmenter les droits
de taxer de mettre des péages d'emblée
est-ce que certaines pistes de réflexion
que vous écarteriez vous déjà
ce qui est certain c'est que il ne faut
pas encourager l'achat de nouveaux
véhicules donc on est dans un on est en
dans un contexte de transition
énergétique et de mobilité durable tout
ça ça s'inscrit aussi dans la politique
de mobilité durable du gouvernement
actuel et ce gouvernement là dans sa
politique de mobilité durable comme
premier objectif de réduire le nombre de
dents de déplacements sur les routes
donc il ne faut pas encourager des
véhicules donc tout ce qui est
remise sur des véhicules même des
véhicules et peu énerve peu énergivores
ça devrait être écarté puisque en aucun
cas on peut se permettre de
subventionner des véhicules individuels
privés puisqu'il faut au contraire
favoriser le covoiturage de transport en
commun le transport actif donc tout ce
qui est subvention ou remise sur des
véhicules devraient être écartés dès le
début d'ailleurs vous monsieur Pinault
je crois comprendre que vous avez une
préférence pour le concept de la
contribution kilométrique expliquer nous
bon comment ça fonctionne comment on
pourrait mettre ça en place taxer les
déplacements à la distance si on veut
je pense que c'est la meilleure manière
parce que ça se rapproche le plus du
concept d'utilisateur payeurs ou de
pollueur payeur on sait que
l'utilisation des routes les routes
coûtent cher et donc c'est normal que
ceux qui les utilisent le plus paye
davantage ça pourrait être mis en oeuvre
de manière extrêmement simple nous avons
tous sur les véhicules un odomètre qui
regarde le kilométrage que l'on fait et
donc on pourrait faire des relevés
annuels du nombre de kilomètres que l'on
fait ça se fait déjà dans pour les
assurances automobiles de mettre une
contribution qui est proportionnelle au
nombre de kilomètres qu'on a parcouru
les assurances automobiles dit si vous
parcourez peu de kilomètres et bien on
va moins vous demander en termes de
contribution d'assurance si vous êtes un
par contre quelqu'un qui roule beaucoup
on vous allez payer plus en termes
d'assurance automobile donc ça serait
sur le même principe c'est déjà appliqué
pour les assurances automobiles ça
pourrait être facilement modulable selon
les les emplacements les lieux de
résidence des gens les gens qui habitent
en région
payer moins cher comme redevance
kilométrique ou comme contribution
kilométrique que des gens qui habitent
en ville et donc il y aurait différentes
manières de le mettre en oeuvre ça
pourrait être très peu technologique
comme je le souligne avec une simple
lecture de l'odomètre ou alors ça
pourrait être très technologique avec
une des puces dans les voitures qui
mesurent en temps réel avec des GPS le
nombre de kilomètres parcourus cette
option ou pas ou un bouquet de mesure
monsieur Pinault dans le choix de de ces
mesures là on devra considérer plusieurs
choses l'impact pour le budget des
ménages des questions d'équité fiscale
pour les moyens anti-excité
territoriales vous venez de l'évoquer
est-ce que vous croyez une solution
unique où on devra se tourner vers
plusieurs mesures différentes
je pense qu'il va falloir de toute façon
effectivement plusieurs mesures
différentes c'est certain que les plus
gros véhicules vous venez de mentionner
tout à l'heure dans les statistiques
démontrent les Québécois préfèrent les
gros véhicules malheureusement ce ne
sont pas des véhicules qui sont
compatibles avec la transition
énergétique que nous devons faire ce
sont des véhicules qui même s'ils sont
électriques demandent plus d'énergie
pour leur construction et encourage à ce
qu'on les utilise davantage donc je
crois qu'il va falloir combiner des
redevances à l'immatriculation qui sont
plus élevées et une taxe kilométrique
pour pouvoir équilibrer les différentes
les différentes options très bien merci
beaucoup pour vos explications très
claires monsieur Pinault
ça me fait plaisir au revoir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]